and I think at the highest level what
I've thought about in terms of wealth
and that I really believe in terms of
wealth and I'm studying this stuff for
so many years and studying other wealthy
people and thinking about money myself
is I think what wealth can really do for
you that will legitimately make most
people happy is to the extent that you
can use wealth to control your time to
give yourself options to let you do what
you want when you want with who you want
for as long as you want to
that is wealth great power mr. Morgan
Housel in the building how are you man
I'm good thanks for having me excited to
be here thanks Chris
yeah me too me too we're talking wealth
today right everyone everyone wants it
but I don't know how many get it it's
it's very elusive know how to get it I
think it's a lot of people don't even
think about defining what it is or what
it's gonna mean to them or what it could
do for them or why they want it I think
there's just a natural urge to want more
of it but answering the question why it
seems like a funny question to a lot of
people like of course I want to be
wealthy why would you even ask but you
start getting these like more
philosophical questions and like why do
you want to be wealthy is it a status
thing is it because you want more stuff
is it because you want more control over
your time is it because you think it's
gonna erase problems and you know that
you can currently have in your life if
you have more money those problems will
go away and I think there's a lot of
different elements to that and I think
at the highest level what I've thought
about in terms of wealth and that I
really believe in terms of wealth and
I'm studying this stuff for so many
years and studying other wealthy people
and thinking about money myself is I
think what wealth can really do for you
that will legitimately make most people
happy is to the extent that you can use
wealth to control your time to give
yourself options to let you do what you
want when you want with who you want for
as long as you want to that is wealth
great power that you can do for us but
that's usually not what people think
about wealth wanting to do for them
usually what they think about it is more
stuff bigger house nicer car or better
clothes maybe some travel whatnot and
there's nothing wrong with that I like
fancy cars I like big homes they like it
all but we just have so much evidence is
almost it's it's it's
cliche at this point to say you know
buying the bigger house and the fancier
car won't make people happy we've a lot
of evidence on that that there's this
heat on a treadmill that people when
they're anticipating getting the Ferrari
that's really exciting but then they
actually get it they say yeah it's just
a car it's it's got a steering wheel and
whatnot and there's a lot of different
elements to that I think what's really
this is something I learned when I used
to be a valet at a fancy hotel in Los
Angeles when I was in college these
people would come in driving their
Ferraris and I would look at that I
would look at the car I'd be like wow
that's would it be cool if I had that
car would it be cool if I was driving
that Ferrari and it took me a while to
realize the irony of that thought which
was that those people drove in and I
never said wow that driver the guy
driving the Ferrari he is really cool
he must be impressive as an observer I
just said I want to be in that car I
didn't care about the driver all I did
is I imagined myself driving his car but
the guy driving in when he's driving the
Ferrari he's probably thinking everyone
thinks I'm cool and they didn't the
people the valet on the curb was
thinking I want to be in like I don't
care about you I just want to imagine
myself be sitting in that seat and I do
it's just like this irony of like no one
cares about the guy in the car but
everyone wants to be the guy I like to
the extent that you wanted buy a fright
and a Ferrari is like of course the
extreme example doesn't mean you need to
be that luxurious but the extent that
you want wealth to buy you stuff because
you think it's gonna bring you respect
and admiration and prestige I think it
you know there's probably some of that
that has a good signaling effect but to
a lot of that is just a misconception
about you think people are thinking X
but they're actually thinking like I
think that's a big reason why the
perception of being wealthier seems like
oh I'm gonna be so much happier when I'm
wealthy but if you look at the
statistics about how happy wealthy
people are they're just they're not that
much help they're not that much happier
than the rest of us of course there's
like a minimum level of meeting your
daily needs and comfort and whatnot but
after that a lot of like the status
wealth the its propensity to make people
happy is really not there but I bring
that up because what we know does make
people happier has like a legitimate
lasting long-term impact on their
happiness is when
can control their schedule when they own
their time when they can do what they
want when they want when they could wake
up every single morning seven days a
week and say to themselves I can do
whatever the hell I want today that
makes people happy so if you could use
wealth to generate that to own your
schedule and for ordinary people maybe
that's taking a job that doesn't have a
long commute or you're working in a job
that pays less but it's doing something
that you love or it's something like
that or if it's a you know I have a
higher level retiring early just
retiring when you want to or retiring
when you're 32 you which is like a big
movement these days stuff like that does
make people happy when you can control
your time that's a lasting impact so
when I think about wealth it's like the
highest the fundamental level the first
question is what do you want it to do
for me and for me personally it's just a
level of independence it's a level of
waking up every day and saying I can do
what I want now that's what that's the
goal of well what's for me I get it one
man I've got a million doorways open in
my mind one of them being being rich
might not make you happy but being poor
will make you miserable yes I love I
love that quote and it really is it
really is very very true anyone that you
know it's what I call diet brain you
know you're on a diet and the only thing
that you can think about is food it's
the same exactly precisely the same as
that if you have money worries there is
more thing that happens what is not
framed by but I don't have enough money
but what happens about the next paycheck
but about my bills rate my mother-in-law
brought up an example years and maybe a
decade ago now that I really through
that was really insightful she said
camping is fun being homeless is
miserable goes to is one is a choice and
one is being forced but you're sleeping
in a tent outdoors but rich people and I
say I really have to choose my words
carefully and not you know and I'd
really I'd try to really empathize with
people who are almost but that's I think
that's a great way to frame the extreme
ends of it absolutely is that it's not
even like the absolute conditions that
we're in it's whether we have a choice
to do it or not
yeah and if you're forced to do
something that's against your will you
don't want to be homeless you don't want
to be out sleeping in the cold that is
miserable but if you're if you're
camping it's kind of a thrill to it some
of that is because
one night you're not doing it all the
time but it's just like I thought
framing that as you know just the
difference to me in whether you want to
do it or not makes all the difference in
the world there's this great story about
FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt where his
his mom was talking about I think FDR
was like 10 years old at the time and he
complained to his mom that he was
unhappy in life because his entire day
was structured in a really strict
regimen at 7 a.m. you do this and any of
you do that and he came to his mom and
he said all these rules make me unhappy
so his mom said ok for one day you can
do whatever you want it's all up to you
and his mom wrote in their diary that
night that during that day when FDR
could do anything you want he followed
his own route to his old routine
he did the same he did his homework in
idiom but just just the fact that he was
doing that on his own will rather than
someone telling him to do it made him
feel better
so taking people know what to do and
even if they get to do what they is
they're doing what they want to do on
their own terms they still might do the
same thing but they're doing it on their
own terms and they're camping they're
not homeless that's such a good
distinction that agency the the
allowance to make a choice
another thing is while you were talking
about the guy in the car and it makes me
think about the Navara of account quote
which is um you cannot take part of
someone's life you have to take the
whole it's like you look at the guy in
the car and you think [ __ ] that cars
cool but what's the price he's had to
pay for that car not $250,000 like what
the sacrifices he's had to make that how
many relationships has he destroyed how
many or she has she decided not to have
it for go children so that she can make
it to 40 years old and be the CEO of
some company you don't know what the
price that someone has had to pay to
acquire that wealth is and I think it
comes back to what you said before it
appears to be it's very very essence
what wealth gives someone is freedom
agency control of their own time control
of what it is that they get to do what
they have to do and that's a much more
holistic way of looking at it then like
dan Bilzerian it let's not say that the
dan Bilzerian approach isn't a good
thing but
you getting enough of course I know to
back to your point when you see the
Ferrari you don't see what went on to
getting that Ferrari all you see are the
shiny wheels and the big growling engine
you don't see working till midnight you
don't see you never getting to hang out
with your kids not that everyone who
drives a Ferrari is in that is in that
boat but there's a sacrifice that you
don't see but the person driving that
Ferrari they're acutely aware of it they
know how hard they had to work for that
thing so there's a big difference
between what you see and what actually
what you what it takes to get that stuff
and that I think is another reason why
the perception of wealth feels a lot
better the dream the daydreaming of
wealth feels better than actually having
it because when you actually have it you
know you you you realize all the costs
that are associated with it I think
there's this thing to that once you gain
dwell if a lot of people get paranoid
about losing it and you don't it's it's
not easy to think about that before you
have it when when you're sitting here is
thinking about if I won the lottery what
would life be like you think about all
the fun trips you're gonna take and all
the beautiful house and the beach and
everything a lot of people don't it's
very hard to conceptualize until you're
there what its gonna feel like to think
to yourself what if I lose all of this
what if I make a bad decision what if I
spend it all what if the huge annual
bonus that I got last year that was a
one-time fluke I'm not gonna get that
again and then surf there for maybe I
don't want to spend maybe I want to
hoard this it's hard to really think
about those feelings until you're in the
trenches just imagine those feelings but
those are real feelings that happened
and few other people doing this dough
Gates had a quote I heard him say this a
long time ago but I've yet I have not
been able to define the source from this
so I'm paraphrasing what he said but it
was something to the effect of now that
he's the richest man in the world like
his biggest his only money thought was
not losing what he had it was not
growing more areas more than he could it
was just not losing it and how many
people who are thinking about Bill Gates
as wealth his money mindframe think that
he's singing at home worried about
losing what he has he's got like it's
it's absurd but that's what goes through
people's heads and I think that it's a
really common thing that comes up when
you hear very wealthy people talk about
the psychology of their own money being
paranoid about losing what they have is
a big thing that comes up and that's a
stress that is hard
of course there's a big point of this
where it's like yeah this someone who's
living on the poverty line that's like
oh yeah it sounds really hard exactly
but there's also a sense this is not a
popular statement but first world
problems are our real problems like
anxiety in your head is real no matter
how wealthy or how absurd it looks to
someone else
anxiety is real high blood pressure is
real no matter how crazy it looks and a
lot of people in those situations have
issues that you cannot fathom until
you're in their shoes yeah I was talking
to James all that [ __ ] the other day who
is he's like the patient zero for make
it lose it make it lose it yeah make it
again also as well on that kind of
relativistic worldview I remember this
really early memory with my mom and I
was walking down the street and she I
was complaining about something
something small I was cold or it was wet
or it was whatever and she turned and
said um I was only ten at the time she
turns to Christopher look like there's
bigger problems in the world than you
being cold or wet and I remember turning
to her and saying yes but this is my
world this is the biggest problem in my
world right now we're not absolute
beings we are relative beings right I
mean one person in the world right now
is suffering more than everyone and
everyone else their suffering is just is
all just real right it's always like
it's all on a spectrum and everyone no
matter where you are in the spectrum
like someone is probably there's only
one person who is who is suffering more
than anyone else everyone else is just a
matter of perspective
and we all live on that I mean I wrote a
piece many years ago that a lot of
people did not appreciate but it was it
was during it was in 2011 during the
Occupy Wall Street protest if you
remember that where there was a big
public backlash I think a lot of it was
justified against the 1% and it was the
1% versus the 99% and I wrote a piece
that said look in the United States in
the world if your if your income is over
I think it was $32,000 per year
you're in the top 1% of the world and
everyone so and how many of the people
in the United States saying the 1% are
you know it's unfair they're ruining it
they are actually part of the 1% of the
world and I didn't mean it in this I
just wanted to add some perspective I
wasn't I wouldn't saying that their
protests were wrong I just wanted to say
like it's all a matter of perspective
that we're all stood on this spectrum
and we all kind of think that we are
where we sit is the baseline the
foundation but it's not your foundation
is like the top of the mound for other
people that sphere of awareness is so
biased right like it's not the 1% it's
not done with the 1% it's down with my
1% down with the 1% that I see the 1%
that's close to me yeah that's what it
is um so yes when I say something like
that I'm not saying you can that you
people are out of touch because everyone
lives in their own world everyone like
and again like your problems whether you
are big Bill Gates us problems or
someone else like anxiety is anxiety
fear is fear we're losing sleep is
losing sleep no matter how wealthy you
are it still hurts the same the next
morning so like we it's it's wrong to
say hey because if you make $32,000
you're in the 1% so you should feel
wealthy shame on you for not that's not
the point whatsoever the point is just
you know we all live on this spectrum
and it's all just a matter of
perspective and I think the bigger point
is realizing that people who are on a
much higher spectrum it's not that if
you're on a lower spectrum you should
feel thankful it's at people who are on
a much higher spectrum they also hurt
they hurt as well and sometimes it's not
a popular view I get that but I think I
think to me the bottom line is like no
matter what your wealth is the
psychology of money and what it does to
our feelings and our well-being and the
lack thereof is pretty universal
absolutely so let's get into it let's
talk about the basics of wealth creation
what is what is wealth is there a
difference between being wealthy and
rich and how do I get it
I think if there is a difference of
course this is just this is just
semantics this is not and you know this
is sort of something I've made up but my
definition of rich is you have a big
income big relative to your peers around
you so of course that's a big range as
well but if you have an income higher
than most of people around your peer
group you can call yourself rich wealthy
is much different because wealthy is you
have assets in the bank that
you can spend in the future that's very
different from being rich because a lot
of people will have a large income this
year but they're not saving any of it
they're on the razor's edge of
insolvency they're blowing through all
of it as quickly as they can and those
are there a lot of people who are rich
in that sense but not necessarily
wealthy years ago Chris Rock one of my
favorite comedians made made it was in
one of his skits and he was talking
about the difference between rich and
wealthy and he says and I have to
preface of saying this is Chris Rock
joke I'm not taking about taking credit
for any of the social dynamics of this
but he said he said Shaq is rich the guy
who signs his cheque is wealthy and the
thing is like no Shaq as well jack is
like he's he's got an empire but I
thought that was like a great way to
frame it that applies to a lot of us too
because there are people who make
$40,000 a year that save a lot of it and
they're wealthy and there are people who
make five million dollars a year that
blow that spend six million a year and
they are on the razor's edge of poverty
so it's just a big relative thing that
doesn't like rich has to do with your
income but wealth has to do with your
savings rate and savings rate is totally
independent of your of your richness
okay your your your annual income and
we've seen this in a big way in the last
decade when the fire movement financial
independence retire early movement came
along where you have people who are
making 40 50 grand a year's you know
sometimes more 100 200 grand a year they
live a very low-key lifestyle and they
save 50 percent of it or more and those
are people whose incomes are not that
impressive but they're wealthy and you
can compare that to a lot of people that
we've heard of and I'm writing about I'm
reading a book on psychology and money
right now that starts with a story about
someone who made a tremendous amount of
money on an annual basis and blew it all
and went bankrupt and so you know we I
think we are very often think that
wealth is just how much money you make
and there's a lot of evidence that
that's not it it's a personal lifestyle
choice more than it is anything to do
with the number of zeroes in your annual
income
and so to me it's just been about you
know it's less how much money you make
or what your investment returns are and
more just in the decisions that you make
about how you're gonna spend your money
and what you value in life do you value
a big car do you value fancy clothes do
you value value jewelry going out to
dinner bunnies people forelock people
including me some of those answers are
yes I do value those things but there
are other things I really don't value
whatsoever and I would rather save money
to build wealth and that wealth that you
save is what you it's what people don't
see so it's the like wealth is the the
Ferrari that you did not buy it's the
car you didn't buy it's the square
footage that you did not buy it's the
first class thing that you didn't buy
and I think that's like of course that's
what it is wealth is what you don't
spend it's the wealth it's somebody that
you saved up the problem with that is
that when we when you and I and everyone
else is trying to look at the world and
see how other people are managing their
money all we see is what they spent we
don't see what they didn't spend I see
the car that you drive I see the house
that you're in I don't the house that
you could have afforded but you did not
buy and that house that you could afford
it it my dad's you're Buffett right now
the part of you w that you could have
bought that you didn't that's your
wealth but I never see that and that's
why I think a lot of people have this
misconception of what wealth is is
because we don't see it and I've used
the analogy of like you know when people
exercise they get into good shape and
being in good shape is something that
you can see you can see muscles you can
see you know thinness you can see that
you can see the opposite of exercise it
comes in obesity and whatnot and then
they're forced so everyone else viewing
you I can look at you Chris and saying
you look like you're in good shape I can
see that you come I can see that you
exercise because I can see it but but I
have no idea what your net worth I can't
see your bank account I can see your
physique but I cannot see your bank
account and that's why I think something
like exercise is something that it's not
very controverted is they have a role
models they have anti models wealth is
totally different for wealth there's
people who live they you they you know I
think almost everyone knows someone who
is ten times wealthier than you think
but you don't know that because you
can't see it but there's no but there's
no one
is ten times heavier as you can see it
so I think like the fact that it's just
hard to see wealth makes it very
difficult for people to wrap their head
around and learn about absolutely again
I can you can tell that I'm currently
spending a lot of time researching
Navarre Rob account because every quote
I'm coming out with his his but the
forefront of my mind and he has a thing
where he talks about socialized rewards
versus internalized rewards he asked
about the gym being a socialized reward
meditation being an internalized
rewardin and that's precisely the same
dichotomy that we've got going on here
right and even the wealth that some
people have that is being shown outward
as you've identified it's not real
wealth I absolutely love that quote that
your wealth is the Ferrari that you
didn't buy it's the square footage a
house that you didn't choose I think
that's such a great heuristic for people
to use and again with that this is the
sort of message which I think helps to
educate people about what wealth is we
are mimetic beings right we just look
around and see what other people are
doing you like that guy's got money that
guy's got a fancy car what's he doing
with his money it must be fine and you
just oh well right I'll take that you
know we don't learn about how to become
wealthy in school so I'll just learn by
proxy of what other people do that have
money but you don't know if that guy as
you say that guy's just on that absolute
razor's edge and next month next year
he's going to be filing for bankruptcy
so be sure and here's the thing like
there are of course there are a lot of
people who drive Ferraris who are
legitimately wealth but the only thing
you know about their wealth is that you
have two hundred fifty thousand dollars
less than they had before they had the
car that's all you know about it so
there there is a lie and there's also a
lot of people driving Honda Civics
driving Honda Accords driving Toyota
Camrys that are very very wealthy but
you would never know it so we just don't
know how size these people up and when
you don't know how to size someone else
up most people have a lot of
misconceptions there's a lot of
distorted thoughts about what wealth is
and how its generated that is I think
why this topic is so difficult called
and sets people on a painful path very
often don't you so fundamentals is
wealth just what you don't spend is that
it or is it more about things that
generate money on there
Oh nor is it money in the bank is it if
I've got assets that are earning
passively how does that all fit together
I think I think less about that it's
more just what you've chose not to spend
take the most extreme example in the
world Jeff Bezos Bill Gates they both
worth let's just round and say they're
both worth about a hundred billion
dollars they could have spent that money
in the past Jeff Bezos could have sold
all of his Amazon stock in 2001 and gone
and gone out and done whatever but he
didn't he left it there
so his wealth is what he did not spend
that's true for everyone in every income
level so and to me it's less about how
much you're earning on that wealth
whether it's like cash in the bank
earning no interest that's well Stockton
in the next one that's well even the
equity in your home your real estate
that's wealth you know it's not liquid
wealth but it's still well it's just
what you have not spent because I think
anything that you could spend but you
have not spent as well as that's what it
is if you have you have the option to
spend it and you choose not to that is
to me that's a definition of wealth love
it so how do I go about I just need to
spend less I need to have money in the
bank account are there any real
fundamental principles about how I can
maximize my wealth how I can make the
most of it the easiest way Chris is just
to be born to a wealthy parent yeah yeah
dynasty money that's what I want
honestly I think people very often
overlook not the money that they
necessarily inherit from their parents
but how much how many doors are either
open or closed for you based on who your
parents are - karma is under who has
shown that income among brothers is more
correlated than height or weight so
literally if you have a brother that is
tall and rich you are more likely to be
rich than you are tall that's not work
for lady it's more like the income among
brothers is more hereditary than haider
way because those brothers probably had
the same educational opportunities they
probably had the same doors opened by
their parents in terms of hey I can get
your job or I can't get you a job I can
send you to a good school or I can't
send you to a good school so it's not
like it goes both ways the income is
correlated on the downside on the upside
and it's it's easy for a lot of people
to to
over look how powerful that is that some
people are just born on a very different
base and it's no one wants to I think if
you are very successful you don't want
to say well I just got lucky like
successful people don't want to say that
and but of course it's true it's always
true you know I've written before it's
something really minor that might not
seem like a big deal but to me it's just
it's just extraordinary
Bill Gates went to the only High School
in America that had a computer I think
you think of you think about that and
it's just like of course he was lucky
that's not to say that he's not talented
he's not smart he's not motivated he's
all those things but look where he
started and was and he had no input on
that he went to this high school was
called lakeside school in Seattle I I
believe the story was because he was
kind of he was very smart and not doing
well at his old school because he was so
much smarter than the other kids so his
parents put him in this private school
like science yeah but I happened to have
a computer and he found it and who else
was at the school was I was Paul Allen
the other you know he would Paul Allen
was at the same school and they started
working on this computer together and
then and and the Microsoft came out of
it that's not to say that dole Gates
would not be enormous ly successful
anywhere else but he would not be
Microsoft Bill Gates he might be
attorney Bill Gates or dr. Bill Gates
very successful entrepreneur Bill Gates
but not a hundred billion dollar bill
Gates they that part was a luck and he's
admitted as he said this is not a direct
quote but he said something to the
effect of without Lakeside there and
there would not be Microsoft that might
actually be a direct quote but I don't
know is very close to that so he's not
in denial about this but I think there's
that for everyone I had a certain amount
of luck you had a certain everyone has a
certain ton of luck and misfortune dole
Gates had a certain amount of misfortune
Bill Gates not to harp too much on this
but when Bill Gates was in school he had
his best friend was name's Kent I'm
forgetting his last name but his name
was Kent and bill and Kent were the two
computer geeks and they did everything
together they were like inseparable best
friends they were equals in terms of
their computer programming ability and
Bill Gates said this is in the
documentary it's on Netflix Bill Gates
was reminiscing
about Kent and said yeah you know Kent
and I I'm sure we would have gone to
college together and we would have we
would have worked together Kent may have
been the co-founder of Microsoft but he
died in a mountaineering accident when
he was like 18 years old so that's like
that's the other side of Bill Gates are
extraordinarily lucky Kent got
extraordinarily unlucky and that's like
risk and luck of us that are that are
the opposite sides of the same coin
they're both this idea that our outcomes
in life are influenced by more than just
the effort that we put into life and
that I think people know that of course
but it's so easy to underestimate how
powerful those things are and then so to
bring all this back when you said how do
I get wealth you know there I'm saying
it tongue-in-cheek but there's a really
true statement in here of like you have
to be born lucky you don't have to be
born lucky but oh my gosh does it help
and no one should pretend that you know
a college-educated white male in the
United States is on the same plane as a
child born in Somalia you know and of
course that's an extreme example but we
own them everywhere within there there's
a very powerful spectrum and so that's
that's a huge part of building off that
we shouldn't overlook and then that's
that's the first point I want to make
the second point is so much and we
talked about this earlier so much of
building wealth is just the lifestyle
that you choose to leave you you choose
to lead and this is true at all incomes
groups but living below your means is
everything at any income group and
choosing to live below your means isn't
a single most important thing to do to
build wealth and a lot of what that is
of what living below you means is is
just suppressing your ego to say I could
spend X I could spend 10 but I'm only
going to spend 8 and the difference
between the two is like my ego going
down like I could have a nicer car but I
know I know I'm not gonna do it I could
have more clothes but no I'm not gonna
do it it's that gap that you're pushing
against that's really meaningful I the
point that I made recently about where
you really get a benefit from exercising
is after you exercise and you're very
hungry because you just burn 500
calories and saying I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna replace those calories with a
cheeseburger
my body is saying hey you're hungry
Chris you're hungry because you just
exercise go eat a cheeseburger you're
saying no I'm
to suppress that hunger that's the
benefit of exercise its suppressing that
really helps you even though you think
even though you feel like you've earned
it right you feel like you've earned a
cheeseburger you feel like you've earned
the money the money is in your account I
worked hard for this money I should be
able to spend it but you have to
willingly say I could and I deserve it
but I'm not going to and it's not it's
not the earning it's the it's that push
down that is what wealth is and that to
me I think is really important it just
gets back to like the fire movement of
people who make fifty grand a year but
that's safe half of it they just have a
tremendous propensity to keep pushing
down down down and they're wealthy
because of it and because they're
wealthy they have control over their
time they can retire early they can do
whatever the hell they want and they're
happy for it how much of someone's
setpoint their materialistic setpoint do
you think is predetermined and how much
is in our control because I'm fascinated
by thinking about this I very
fortunately I've a low set point for
materialism right I don't take it
doesn't take much materialistically to
make me happy I like nice things but
like a new night t-shirt which I'm
currently wearing or you know like
whatever like you know I'm not I don't
have huge huge materialistic goals but I
can imagine in some other iteration of
the world if my mom and dad had been
more like keeping it with the Joneses
when I was growing up and that you're
what you wore was a marker of your worth
and and other things like that
I can imagine a very different me how
much of that do you think can kind of be
learned and unlearned I think I think
you're onto something really powerful I
think a very extreme example of this but
that we see very often are people who
come from very poor backgrounds and
become professional athletes and they
might go from literally from food stamps
to making 20 million dollars a year and
I think those people have a much higher
propensity for flash for the biggest
homes and the fanciest cars because it's
like it's like a chip on the shoulder
from their past and showing like I've
like I used to be there but now I'm up
here whereas if you're born with a
certain level of wealth I think there's
less just trying to prove yourself you
just kind of like this is me and
I'm where I I don't really have much to
prove this is just who I am and humans
who have always been so I think you're
onto something really really important
which is kind of how you're right not
just how you're raised but your social
status in life is really important my my
wife I say this with confidence my wife
will love me no matter what clothes I'm
wearing or car I'm driving if that were
not the case if I did not get as lucky
with my spouse and I had a spouse who
was really adamant that I Drive the
fanciest car I might have a much higher
propensity to spend then I do today so
has my spending been influenced by the
way in which my spouse loves me
absolutely and that's you know I can't
say it's easy for me to say I'm frugal
and I don't spend that much money and
therefore you should too when things
that are outside of my control like this
spouse that I happen to get lucky it has
a big influence on my spending and
that's why it's there's really no
one-size-fits-all advice and I sometimes
I really get upset with not upset but I
I don't I don't like financial pundits
or financial advisors who say you should
do this I think it's different for
everybody and so I think if you can add
context about how people think about
wealth and try to add different
perspectives and think about it but then
saying now that I've maybe helped you
think about it you got to go figure out
what works for you it was kind of the
way to do it because we're all in such
different we all have different goals
well have different aspirations they've
come from very different backgrounds
we've seen the world through a totally
different lens through no fault of our
own it's not because I'm smarter than
you or you're smarter than me it's just
we've seen the world in a different area
through different lens so people have
very different views on what's important
to them yeah and that was a big
influence on spending one of the things
that I tell the guys that work for us we
have a lot of formative years the adult
formative years as I call them 18 to 21
big group of university students who
come and work for us it's their first
professional position it's the first
time they've earned even a moderate
amount of money usually and I'm talking
to them about the way that they spend
their money and I'm like look man like
you have two choices here you can choose
to keep some back and then spend on the
summer holiday or whatever it is or you
can continue to spend as you earn as it
comes in
but if you
real this materialistic lifestyle now
and you don't break that habit it's
gonna be number one harder for you to do
later in life and number two if you
still have a materialistic habit when
you get to be in your later adult years
you'd better hope that you've got an
amazing job because if you don't have an
amazing job and you've still got this
materialism trigger going like you are
in for a very very tough time because
you're never gonna feel good enough
you're never gonna feel like you're
earning enough yeah I think I think that
brings us back to another analogy about
athletes I never hearing a football
player said who said a lot of former NFL
players are very obese or just morbidly
obese and the reason why that occurs is
because after they after their football
careers are over there eating stays the
same but their exercises lunch and I
think it's I think that's and it's I I
really I'm sure that's the case if you
get used to eating 10,000 calories a day
and that's just your baseline this was
what you do you wake up and you eat a
seven egg omelet that's just what you do
but you go from working out four hours a
day to one hour a week or whatever it is
that's gonna that's gonna make a big
impact and I think it's very similar for
income and spending as well if you're
making a great income and you're
spending a ton of money you're you set
your baseline about what that's like
your baseline for eating it's like III
only feel good from spending X or if I'm
eating X and then if your income falls
for whatever reason and I think everyone
will go through a period in their life
with their income Falls at some point
some worse than others but everyone will
go through that at some point you better
hope that your spending is in line with
whatever your new income is and it's
very difficult to go down going down in
life is so difficult going down one inch
is so difficult and going up ten feet
can feel like just okay no one ever
wants to go down if you have to if you
have to downsize your house against your
will just because it's what you can't
afford
that's gonna have a big impact on your
well-being so to me it's just like
creating a gap between likely future
scenarios to turn my income of like my
income going down and what I'm spending
today and just making sure that you know
asking yourself if my income fell by
five percent ten percent fifty percent
would that do to my spending right now
and
and maybe some like 50% is is too
extreme to think about for some people
but for loud people it's not and I think
just looking at your your habits in life
and saying like maybe this works right
now but let me think about alternative
scenarios in the future
and I think in the biggest Guardian of
your happiness and your well-being is
having the biggest gap in between what
you need to spend to be happy and what
could happen to your income in the
future the wider that gap is the better
you're gonna be because that's your your
your decreasing the scenarios in which
you're ever gonna have to push your
spending level down in bill safety net
if you can have a situation where your
income can fall 30 or 50 percent and you
still don't need to change your spending
you're you're probably you're like in
terms of financial happiness well-being
you're probably gonna be set for life if
you're in a situation where if you take
a 3% pay cut and you got to sell your
car and that's not an extreme exact
reason Aereo that I just proposed you're
gonna have a really hard time in life so
I think setting these things that you
have control about how much money you
spend a lot of for a lot of people how
much money you make is not necessarily
that in your control to a great extent
but how much you spend is much more in
your control and I think it's the more
important part of the equation that how
much money you make in terms of
financial well-being I love it going
back to the point that you mentioned
about people getting lucky there's this
is like hyper cliche now right of that
guy that we all know that put $1,000
into Bitcoin fifteen years ago and just
through the sheer ridiculous market
return now it doesn't need to do
anything you know that's a perfect
example I've just I've just sort of had
in my head about that um one of the
questions that got off Matt from podcast
notes this is specific to Bitcoin there
might be some people listening who think
that cryptocurrency I've heard I can
make make my fortune on that like
there's this guy in the internet and 50
cent once made it like it whatever and
then then he sold it to fit meme or
whatever it was question is is there any
reason it doesn't make sense to invest 1
to 5 percent of your net worth into
Bitcoin I think that can make sense for
a lot of people it does not make sense
if the calculator doing is by saying oh
I can only put one person in but
bitcoins gonna go up ten thousandfold so
that 1% is still gonna make me rich
if that's your calculus I think it's
it's just setting your expectations of
look bic one's gone up a lot in the last
decade what does that mean for it going
forward no one has any idea I really
don't think anyone has any idea it's not
to say that you shouldn't you shouldn't
own it a lot of very smart people that I
know and was thinking and decisions I
really respect own more than 1% of their
money in the in Bitcoin I think if
you're looking at it as a flyer in terms
of this is probably not gonna do
anything but there's a small chance that
it's gonna do well and fine I think it's
also fine to add 1% of your money in
Bitcoin if you just think it's
intellectually stimulating you like the
math behind crypto and cryptography it's
really interesting to you I think that's
great we don't have to make our
portfolios based off of you know the
perfect academic portfolio of how we
gotta maximize returns I think if if
your portfolio is interesting to you
intellectually stimulating to you and it
helps you sleep at night and it keeps
you engaged with your money versus just
forgetting about it and ignoring it I
think that's a great thing so I don't
personally own any Bitcoin but a lot of
people who are respective that's kind of
like a patreon for content providers
right it's like I've got my favorite
youtuber and I'm gonna put some some
money towards in making this thing so I
really love blockchain so I'm gonna put
money into something that contributes to
the blockchain and now I feel like I'm a
private yeah that's a part of it
people feel good about that the biggest
variable in terms of how well you will
do in your investment portfolio this is
true whether it's stocks or real estate
or Bitcoin or anything is your ability
to maintain those investments when times
get hard when there's a bear market when
bitcoins gone down and your stocks have
gone down if you can still just hold on
during those periods and hold on and
hold an asset for 10 or 20 or 30 years
that's the variable that's gonna really
determine your success and if you love
an accent you love Bitcoin you love
Google stock you love reels that
whatever it is if you love it and by the
fact that you love it means that you're
gonna be more likely to hold on to it
from the long run
that's a good thing that's a great thing
so a lot of people there a lot of
investors who will say almost like as a
badge of honor I'm not I'm not attached
to my investments I'm very unemotional
investments and they're proud of that
and I'm often thought that's not
something to be proud of I think you
want to love your investments because if
you love them you're more likely to
stick around with them when they get
hard if you don't love your investments
and then you know you own some stocks
and they have a bad year and you're like
ah you know I don't love these I'm just
gonna get rid of them just sell them
that is gonna impact your performance do
it in a huge way over time whereas if
you love your investments and and even
in the bad year you say look Google
stocks down 30% but I'm I love Google
I'm sticking with it that's gonna pay
off in the long run so I think because
in any asset no matter what it is you
get paid to deal with uncertainty that's
that's where paychecks come from in the
investing world like people don't often
ask the question that you can make a lot
of money in investing why who's giving
you this money why are you making money
you have to give something up it's not
free what is the cost of returns there's
there's an admission price that you have
to pay and the price that you have to
pay for any investment is dealing with
uncertainty it's dealing with saying I'm
gonna put a thousand dollars in this
stock and it might go down it might go
up it might flatline
but over time I think it's going to do
well and dealing with that uncertainty
is what you get paid for so if you can
stick with an asset when it's out of
favor what's going through your period
where it's not doing well if you can
stick with that rather than saying oh if
it's not doing well I don't want it
anymore your ability to stick with it
and put up with the hard times is what
you get paid for in investing that's
where the money comes from that's the
price of admission and I think people
who only want the upside and are not
willing to put in the downside or when
the downside comes in to say I don't
want this I don't want to own these
stocks anymore those are people who are
trying to sneak into a Disneyland
they're not paying the they're not
paying the cost of admission they don't
want to pay the price and I think if
you're willing to pay the price the
rewards are great
so if you can just put up with the
downside that and and view the downside
as this is what I'm getting this is this
is why I'm gonna get this is not a
punishment but this is the specific
reason that I'm gonna do well over time
and if you don't want to pay that price
there are other assets that you can you
can go in that have
certain returns like cash you know the
return on cash is very predictable
you're not gonna lose money on your cash
you're gonna earn 1% a year it's very
predictable but it's a low return if you
can take a variable return on certain
term that's where the big rewards come
from so I think you know just viewing it
as a cost of admission rather than a
fine for doing something wrong is a
really important way to view volatility
no matter what your investing is -
lovely wait a frame it's the same as
going to the gym right the discomfort in
the gym is the growth that is precisely
what's triggering the growth if someone
said I don't like exercising or someone
said exercising doesn't work because my
arms hurt after I do bicep curls they're
supposed to hurt that's the point you're
tearing your muscles and it hurts and
it'll grow back - bigger that's the
whole frickin point and I think for
people that makes sense in investing and
they'll more dough for exercising I
should say and they almost like it like
oh I'm so sore the next day it was a
good workout they get it but no one says
all that brokers in town in my brokerage
accounts down 30% this is a good so
we've spoken there about the success of
people who were able to predict things
though coming forward you know there's
all Forex signals online and you know
the number of websites who can give you
advice about what stocks to buy for this
year and stuff like that but I know I've
read some stuff that you've about the
relative success of investors who've
actively played the market versus those
who've just put their money into a fund
or an index and just left it do you have
some some examples of that I think the
biggest thing in general just as a
starting comment here the history of the
accuracy and economic forecasting
investing forecasting is very very bad
even the smartest people with the most
information the ability to truly predict
what's going to happen next in the
economy and the stock market is
horrendous this is true across
generations a crowd around the world
it's just not something we're very good
at and there's two ways to look at that
you could say one we're just not smart
enough we're not looking at the right
data when we're doing we're doing this
wrong and that's why it's we're not very
good at predicting what's gonna happen
next I don't really think that's the
case I think people if we know what
events were looking at and we have the
data I think people actually are pretty
good at predicting what's gonna happen
next
but we're still not good at forecasting
because we can't predict we cannot
analyze we cannot forecast events that
we can't even think about because
they're complete surprises that know
that ever think about we just give you
this current example the biggest story
of the global economy and the global
economy right now is the coronavirus how
many people if you go back three weeks
ago not saying ten years but like three
weeks ago when every Wall Street analyst
was putting out their 2020 forecast
here's what to expect in the global
economy for 2020 how many people said
coronavirus zero that example is true
all the time but the biggest news story
is what no one's talking about and what
makes a big story is specifically that
no one's talking about because they
can't prepare for it so it's not that
we're bad at forecasting economy because
we're not doing the right calculations
it's that we can't calculate things that
are unknown and the unknowns are always
what moves the needle the most if you go
back historically September 11th huge
impact on the economy and on September
10th no one except the terrorists were
involved that could have known that it
was coming no one it was not it was not
that our models did not accurately know
didn't didn't accurately analyze what
was going to happen on September 11 they
just did not know what was going to
happen
Pearl Harbor is another example you know
Lehman Brothers not being able to find a
buyer in 2008 these are all things that
no one that day before could have known
they were gonna happen and things that
are some that are surprising are always
the biggest risk because people have a
very good ability to prepare for things
that they see coming which is why I
think another kind of good analogy from
this from nature is that earthquakes
tend to kill more people per event than
hurricanes and the reason why is because
earthquakes come out in the middle of
nowhere you can't predict them they just
boom they're here whereas hurricanes a
lot of people in the modern developed
world at least can have a one-week war
before it comes they can bore up their
windows they can evacuate of course
that's not a blanket statement because
there's people that like Hurricane
Katrina where he just didn't we could
not evacuate we did not evacuate people
so it's not a blanket statement but
earthquakes are deadly because no one
can see them coming and no one can
prepare for them and that's what makes
them that's what makes them so dangerous
the just the specific fact that they are
surprises is what makes them dangerous
and that's true for the economy as well
so every the smartest people will say
what is the biggest economic risk for
2020 or 2019
I think the right answer is always no
matter what year it is is the biggest
risk is what we're not talking about and
we can't talk about things that we don't
know that's always the case and a lot of
people think that's kind of a [ __ ]
answer but that's I think it's always
it's always the case the biggest risk is
what we don't see I've got a article
clipping here from richard chaton who's
a past modern wisdom destiny tweeted
this out recently and this is just pure
Morgan Housel it's got your name written
all over it aj bell the investment
platform found that the 10 shares in the
footsie 350 index with the highest
proportion of sell ratings from analysts
had generated a positive return on
average of 28.9% last year that was
greater than the twenty three point two
percent return generated on average by
the ten-foot c350 stocks with the
biggest proportion of buy ratings yeah
that's that's that's that kind of
analysis to the United States it's
almost always the case so that that's a
different story but I think it's just
classic country I think well there's
several things going on we could say
it's contrarian ISM in because they had
sell ratings the stocks were cheap and
because they were cheap they went on to
do well I think that's profits that's
partially true a lot of it though is
that the narratives that make sense a
lot of will say this stock is a sell o
because X Y & Z because it's industry is
contracting because its management teams
not very good a lot of those narratives
that makes sense and are comfortable for
analyst even smart analysts to put out
there or not actually what drive stock
prices over time it might make sense
that you know
if this industry is contracting the
stock is going to perform poorly but
there are so many other variables that
influence stock prices that don't fit
those really clean narratives you know
if the stock market as a whole is going
up that even if that company's industry
is going down the stocks don't go up -
just because everything is kind of
moving you know there's for every
individual stock there's kind of three
general dynamics that will move it
around up or down there's the movement
of the overall stock market there's the
movement of that industry and then
there's movement of that individual
company and a lot of times we're
analyzing a company we're just thinking
about the news that affects that company
or maybe just that industry but there's
also these other forces that have
nothing to do with the company or with
the industry that have a big influence
on stock prices if this is late 2008
every stock went down it didn't matter
if the companies were doing well if they
were in an industry that was recession
proof everything with them and if this
is 20 19 or 20 13 everything went up I'm
speaking very generally that's not it's
not 100% true but it's very broadly true
just because there were other macro
forces that were independent of the
company that influence price so I think
that's a part of the reason why the
correlation between analysts estimates
and ratings that are based off of these
narratives that might make a lot of
sense don't have that much relationship
between what could stock to actually do
over the next year do you ever get
really frustrated having to swim through
articles of people who are constantly
saying that they know what's going to
happen in the future financially or
economically no because I don't I don't
swim in that pool I just I go to a
different pool I don't swim there I just
I don't I just don't read that stuff
it's just not relevant to me and I and I
need to be clear that I'm not saying
that it's it's bad that it's wrong
that's worthless that's not what I'm
saying but it's not relevant to the game
that I'm playing some people if you're a
day trader then a lot of that news might
be relevant to you but for me someone
who's trying to invest for the next 40
or 50 years it has no relevance
whatsoever it's not going to influence
my decisions it's definitely not gonna
cause me to take an action so I'm not
gonna read it and I think it's really
important for people to realize that
investors play different games we're not
all playing the same game
some people are day traders
people are trying to manage for the next
quarter some people are trying to manage
for the next 100 years and because we're
playing different games we should not
pretend that all the information is
equally relevant to us and so something
that is is relevant to one person it's
not that I can say that's bad
information and that's it might be good
for someone it's just not right for me
yeah and I just I just try to figure out
what Israel of it to me and that's all I
want to read and everything else and
just I'm not gonna pay any attention to
it
so I suppose one month signal is another
man's noise that's it that's exactly it
and you know this this happens very
often I think it happens a lot on
financial TV where someone says is this
stock a good buy and the right answer
you need to ask is like well for who for
a 22 year old day trader or a 97 year
old widow doesn't like and we should
pretend that those are the same people
so is that a good buy for who that's a
really important question to ask and
just realizing what game you're playing
and only a paint paying attention to
information that is relevant to your
game but you get a lot of danger when
we're you know we're all in the same
field running into each other and we
think we're playing the same game but
we're actually totally totally different
things
that I think is a big cause for investor
confusion and mistake and regret is
taking the cues from people who are
playing different games in you so you
know you own Google stock and it falls
after earnings you might think oh like
maybe think maybe these people know
something that I don't because they're
selling stock maybe I should sell too
but maybe the people who sold it our day
traders and you're a long-term investor
so like it might have made sense for
them to sell and for you to hold that
makes that's not a contradiction that's
not a difference in view it's just a
reflection of different games I love it
Morgan we made it man we made it we made
it to the end we got through wealth we
got through the market we got through
Bitcoin we got through financial
forecasting we've completed it so umm
why can we go people want to hustle you
people want to check out your stuff why
should they had online the biggest area
that I live online is twitter my handle
is Morgan Housel my first name my first
personal lastname and that's where I
spend most of my time online that's
where I'm the most active online and
then my blog is collaborative fun calm
slash blog it's where all
writing look amazing man thank you so
much I'd love to have you back on at
some point in the future we can see how
this this year or later in the years
gone down let's do it and I you know
later this year by a book as my books
coming out it's going to be available
for sale September 7th so maybe when
that's the case let's do another episode
well booked in let's get it let's get it
locked in already man I know what your
schedules like so I'll reserve myself a
date now
[Music]